later this morning the 21 year old
defendant in the Pentagon leaked
documents case is expected to appear in
federal court in Boston charged under
the Espionage Act on Capitol Hill there
will also be a closed-door classified
briefing for members of Congress about
the Fallout from this leak senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge has our story
as 21 year old Air National Guardsman
Jack tecsera was arrested last week by
heavily armed FBI agents investigators
fanned out across the U.S intelligence
agencies to probe the leak and the
Damage why did this individual have
access to this classified information
Tuesday the Air Force secretary told
Congress a complete review of policies
is underway we're all disturbed about it
and we're working very very hard to get
to the bottom of it the breadth of the
information that's been leaked is
problematic as director of the U.S
government's counterintelligence and
security Center bill ebenina was deeply
involved in Major League cases and
examining the damage it's going to take
a lot of agencies and a lot of effort to
put them together and say which one
poses the largest risk for the
intelligence Community or Department of
Defense with respect to our adversaries
they're going line by line through these
documents as part of the damage
assessment line by line and we let the
agency Who provided that information
look at it with their experts to deliver
to say what was in there and where do we
get it from evanina said damage
assessments can take years citing the
2013 League of over a million
surveillance records by Edward Snowden a
government contractor the damage
assessment was comprehensive and it's
still ongoing on Capitol Hill there is
bipartisan criticism of the recent
defense department security failures the
entire National Security Community is
going to have to do a real deep dive to
make sure that it's not as easy as it
was for this guy to take these take
these documents I think we've got to get
the bottom of house our classified
information being protected and who's
got access to it
all questions lawmakers may be asking at
their briefing later today the Air
National Guard unit in Massachusetts
where Tech Sarah worked has had its
Mission suspended and the Pentagon says
the precise number of leaked documents
is still not known Nate
Catherine thank you